Well, to have the tags match, we're beginning a bold here,
so we'd have to end a bold there.
This second example is a bit more complicated.
We have to do these things from the inside out.
We might look over and see, oh, we're ending an italics tag,
so I should begin an italics tag here.
But if we do that, things don't balance well.
We look down and we see this bold later.
Actually, this innermost tag--the i here has to balance with the closing i,
meaning there's a b here--bold--that has to balance with the closing b.
And then here we have an anchor tag beginning,
so we need to have an anchor tag ending.
Shaka was born in about 1787 and throughout his military and political career
united quite a bit of the southern part of Africa,
although these days his reign is viewed with some controversy.